we've got some breaking news coming in
in israel at least two people have been
killed in an attack in the city of tel
aviv police report received reports
rather of shootings at multiple
locations one of them a popular
nighttime hangout in the center of the
city a motive for the attack is not yet
known but it follows a spate of similar
incidents at the end of last month
for more on the story we're joined now
by anya koch in tel aviv where the
attack has happened anya what more do we
know so far
well i'm actually pretty close to where
the attack happened it happened around
200 meters behind me and if you see the
background here you will see that this
place looks really quiet but the attack
and where i'm standing right now is in
downtown tel aviv you could say
you could say at the heart of tel aviv
and usually this place would be bustling
with people it is a thursday night so
this is for most israelis
the start of the the beginning of the
weekend so people a lot of them usually
would be out here and they would go to
the restaurants but they don't do that
anymore they were sent home they were
going home looking for safety and i was
actually trying to get closer to the
side of the attack but was asked by a
policeman to please not to do so because
they he felt that that would not be safe
for me
because the police are still looking for
the perpetrator apparently
the perpetrator
is still on the run
we have been hearing a lot of sirens
downtown we saw a helicopter and this is
the fourth attack within two weeks so
the police has already been on the
highest alert for 12 months
dw correspondent anya koch in tel aviv
thank you anya
you